[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter therae today
we'll be discussing the history of Harry
Potter's only known surviving relatives
the dursley family the dursleys are one
of the most infamous muggle families to
exist within the Wizarding World as his
only living relatives at the time of
Harry's parents deaths these were the
people who unfortunately were given the
responsibility of raising Harry from the
time he was only a one-year-old child
but who are they really and how did they
become such intolerable sorts in today's
video I'll be taking you through a deep
dive into the backstories and lives of
the entire desley family as we know them
let's get to it Vernon dursley to begin
with we have Vernon dursley Harry's
maternal uncle by marriage throughout
Harry's upbringing and Beyond he shows
himself to be a very conventional and
often prejudiced mean-spirited man who
dislikes anything out of the order Henry
including magic and Imagination he
frequently prided himself on being
exceptionally normal and as a result was
incredibly small-minded in fact
appearing normal somehow became one of
the most important aspects of verlin's
Life consumed by the very idea that not
only must he be normal he should also
look that way to his neighbors
colleagues and random strangers on the
street Vernon's Pursuit for elite
normalcy is likely one of the main
drivers that had him sent his one and
only son Dudley should the private
school smeltings which imposed archaic
physical disciplinary measures as well
as terrible uniforms as you can imagine
this is the same school in which Vernon
attended as a boy himself
in adulthood as the Director of a Drill
company known as grunnings Vernon was
also extremely proud of his incredibly
average job which he had made into an
exceptionally uninteresting two-decade
career Power Tools in The Firm of
grunting's were often on his mind and he
found the topic particularly fascinating
to discuss with just about anyone who
would listen the company rewarded his
enthusiasm for this rather mundane job
with a fancy company car and a trophy
both of which he liked to flaunt
excessively
although very little is known about
Vernon's early years and childhood life
it seems almost undeniable that he grew
up in a home that encouraged the pursuit
of a normal life and most certainly took
for granted the rather undeserved
privilege which was thrust upon Vernon
and his family
what we do know for certain is that
Vernon was born the second child to a Mr
and Mrs dursley sometime before the
1960s the dursleys definitely did not
have any magical relations and were
Muggles through and through Verlin grew
up with one other sibling an older
sister named Marjorie whom he
affectionately called Marge in his
adolescence Vernon attended smelting's
Academy before graduating and securing a
job at an office in London where he
eventually became a junior executive
petunia dursley married to Vernon
dursley is of course petunia dursley
born petunia Evans who was Harry's
maternal aunt and sister to Lily Potter
Harry's mum similarly to her husband
petunia was rather obsessed with being
what she believed to be normal together
with Vernon she had one son Dudley who
she reluctantly raised alongside Harry
after the death of her sister
I say reluctantly because before Lily
died petuni had become so critical and
resentful of her sister and her magical
abilities that the two had become
estranged and were no longer speaking
before their estrangement however the
siblings were actually rather close as
children growing up in the industrial
town of cokeworth the two girls would
play together near their home which is
where the pair first met a local
neighborhood Boy by the name of Severus
Snape young Severus is the one who
explained magic Hogwarts and The
Wizarding World to Lily whose magical
talents were just emerging telling her
plainly that she was indeed a witch
after Lily received her acceptance
letter to Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry petunia feared being left
behind and wrote to Hogwarts to plead
with the Headmaster Albus Dumbledore to
let her attend alongside Lily in the
hopes that she may develop magic with
just a little bit of Education although
sympathetic to her plea Dumbledore of
course could not Grant her request which
led to a growing bitterness towards her
sister
jealous that Lily had these magical
abilities and she very clearly did not
but Junior began to turn on her once
beloved sister as well as the very
concept of magic as seen in the
following exchange between the two
you didn't think it was such a freak
school when you wrote to the Headmaster
and begged him to take you petunia
turned Scarlet beg I didn't beg as
always reply it was very kind as the
years went on and Lily became an
accomplished young witch at Hogwarts but
Junior became more and more resentful of
course it didn't help their parents Mr
and Mrs Evans were extremely proud of
young Lily all of these feelings
culminated to the point in which petunia
became openly hostile with her family
and decided to move away to the big city
of London in search for life which
celebrated much more ordinary things to
her great satisfaction she ended up
securing a mind-numbingly normal office
job which is of course where she met
Vernon Vernon and Petunia's Union
petunia and Vernon met while working
together in the same office in London
soon after petunia left her family home
in cokeworth in search of a much more
unimaginative and ordinary life petunia
found Vernon a rather boring and
Prejudiced man to be quite desirable
indeed while the vast majority of people
would recoil at the prospect of dating
someone like Vernon it's likely that
petunia was attracted to the fact that
Vernon was almost the polar opposite of
her family whom she remained incredibly
resentful towards at the time
in any case much to Petunia's excitement
Vernon asked her out and the pair went
on a series of uneventful boring dates
after what Vernon deemed to be the
appropriate amount of time he proposed
to petunia in the sitting room of his
mother's house as you all know she said
yes considering the ages of both Vernon
and petunia when they met this all
likely took place from the two were in
their early 20s in the mid to late 1970s
their wedding was then held sometime
during the final months of the year
1977. a son as briefly mentioned and as
many of you likely already know Dudley
is the only son of Vernon and petunia
dursley he is of course therefore Harris
won and only cousin born on June 23rd in
1980 only about a month before Harry
Dudley and Harry are almost exactly the
same age when Dudley is first introduced
he is an actively spoiled ungrateful and
rather mean child who yells and hits his
parents Harry as well as other children
quite Frank frankly at first Dudley
dursley is given very little redeeming
qualities he thoroughly enjoys bullying
Harry and is delighted to be accepted
into rather behind the time smelting's
Academy as his father was before him he
even parades around in his new uniform
as he practices using his new hitting
stick which is in actual fact a gnarled
cane that is part of the smelting's
uniform however as he grows into young
man Dudley has some experiences that
seem to change him for the better the
main event being his interaction with a
group of Dementors which Harry saves him
from after this particular experience
Dudley seems to become a lot less
insufferable and certainly more
tolerable as a human being
the dursley home number four privet
Drive the familial home of the jerseys
was none other the number four privet
drive a square brick house that was as
you may have guessed incredibly normal
looking it was located on a street lined
with houses that looked almost the exact
same in little whinging a village quite
close to London in the Southeast County
of Surrey
believed that Vernon and petunia
purchased the house in 1977. soon after
they got married this of course would
mean that it was the only home that
Dudley ever knew as a child inside the
house was made up of two floors the main
floor as well as an upper level all of
which was immaculately clean and tidy
thanks to Petunia's persistent efforts
to be perfect and ordinary when first
entering the home there was a living
room followed by a dining area hallway
and kitchen there was also a Stairway
which led to the Upper Floor and
underneath these stairs was the cupboard
in which Harry lived and slept as a
young boy the upstairs is where the
master bedroom was in which Vernon and
petunia slept a spare bedroom Dudley's
main bedroom as well as Dudley's second
room which is where he kept the majority
of his toys this second room of Dudley's
became Harry's bedroom after he received
his acceptance letter from Hogwarts as
Vernon grew very concerned that the
magical Community would not be pleased
by Harry's rather tight and sanitary
accommodations underneath the stairs the
property also boasted Immaculate and
tidy Gardens in both the front and
backyards the dursleys were eventually
forced to move out of number four profit
Drive in 1997. when Harry was relocated
to number 12 grimald place this was done
in an effort to protect Vernon petunia
and Dudley from Voldemort coming after
them as Harry's only surviving relatives
during the dark Lords second rise to
power the order is sure Voldemort will
Target you whether to torture you to try
and find out where I am or because he
thinks by holding you hostage I'd come
and try to rescue you you've got to go
into hiding and the order wants to help
you're being offered serious protection
the best there is
other known family members from what we
know the family tree of the jerseys is a
rather sparse one on petunia side we
know that she had one younger sister
Lily but her parents are only ever
referred to as Mr and Mrs Evans it's
presumed that Mr and Mrs Evans deaths
predated their daughter lilies and that
the Evans had no other extended family
as petunia was the sole person awarded
the responsibility of caring for
orphaned Harry and she is described as
his only known surviving relative on
Vernon's side we are aware that he had a
sister Marjorie dursley the incredibly
dislikable Bulldog breeder but as she
never married nor had children it's
believed that Vernon had no other
relatives there's never any mention of
his parents who are presumed dead due to
their lack of appearance throughout
Harry's childhood how Harry ended up
living with the dursleys considering how
much petunia presented to her family and
grew increasingly more bitter towards
Lily and her magical abilities as the
years went on it may seem a bit strange
that Harry ended up living with her and
her family however this twist of fate
was entirely due to the tragic deaths of
both Lily and James Potter on October
31st 1981 which then resulted in Harry
winding up on the dursley's front
doorstep the following evening the
murders of Lily and James Potter were
the work of the dark wizard Voldemort
after learning of a prophecy that
implicated Harry as the possible means
to which he would meet his downfall the
dark lord decided to go after the Potter
family in an effort to assassinate the
boy before he could grow up to carry out
the prophecy this involved a major
betrayal and breaking of a secret
Keeper's word and resulted in the tragic
deaths of both Lily and James Potter at
the hands of the dark lord however
before Voldemort could also carry out
the murder of young Harry an ancient
form of magical protection was Unleashed
due to Lily Potter's loving sacrifice of
her own life you see despite Voldemort
commanding Lily to step aside from
Harry's crib so that he could carry out
his ass Fascination she instead threw
herself in front of the Dark Lord's
killing curse dying instantly but her
death was not in vain as this act of
incredible bravery not only saved
Harry's life but resulted in the curse
ricocheting back at Voldemort reducing
Voldemort to a shadow version of himself
from there Harry was fared away to
number four privet Drive the home of his
only living family member has Dumbledore
realized that the protection of Harry
that Lily had accidentally invoked
through ancient magic when she
sacrificed her life to save Harry's
could be maintained if he were to cool a
blood relative's house his home of
course this just so happened to be the
dursley's home as Dumbledore explained
to Harry in his fifth year at Hogwarts
while you can still call home the place
where your mother's blood dwells there
you cannot be touched or harmed by
Voldemort he shed her blood but it lives
on Anew and her sister her blood became
your Refuge you need return there only
once a year but as long as you can still
call it home there he cannot hurt you
your aunt knows this I explained what I
had done in the letter I left with you
on her doorstep she knows that allowing
new house room May well have kept you
alive for the past 15 years the
dursley's relationship with the Potters
sadly the once sisterly and loving
relationship of petunia and Lily eroded
over time thanks to Lily's magical
abilities as Lily was celebrated by
their parents for being incredibly
special and talented but Junior felt
increasingly more neglected and
altogether and special I was the only
one who saw her for what she was a freak
but for my mother and father oh no it
was Lily this and Lily that they were
proud of having a witch in the family
her bitterness and resentment towards
her sister only grew worse when she met
Vernon who was openly prejudiced about
people and things that were different or
out of the ordinary and by the time
petunia and Vernon got married her
relationship with Lily was so strained
that she didn't even invite her to be a
bridesmaid this one act combined with
the fact that Vernon wouldn't even speak
to James at the wedding led to the Two
Sisters becoming estranged afterwards
but the only known communication to have
transpired being a card that Lily said
to petunia announcing the birth of their
son Harry as you can imagine the
relationship between the jerseys and The
Potters as a foursome was also quite
strained in fact Virginia was so fearful
of what Vernon would make of her want
wielding sister that she put off
introducing the two for as long as she
possibly could fortunately for petunia
Vernon's response while rather
unfavorable towards Lily was empathetic
to the fact that Lily's Oddities were
not Petunia's fault and he would never
hold it against her that she had a freak
for her sister of course this made for a
rather uncomfortable first meeting
between Vernon petunia Lily and James
essentially dooming the foursome's
relationship forever once married the
dursleys refused to attend Lily and
James's wedding which seems to represent
the official beginnings of their
estrangement the relationship between
the jerseys and The Potters therefore
did not make for a very welcoming home
to the newly orphaned Harry all those
years later and likely accounted for the
terrible way in which both Vernon and
petunia treated him from Vernon's point
of view Harry was no more than a
nuisance and physical representation of
the freaks that his parents had been in
his mind Harry was an incredible threat
to the perfectly ordinary life that he
so prided himself on which we see when
he sends Harry away anytime that the
dursleys have company come to visit
their home Petunia on the other hand
likely saw Harry as the embodiment of
her younger sister and simply
transferred her anger and resented for
Lily onto Harry these feelings were
probably inflamed even more once Harry
receives his letter to Hogwarts
something she had desperately wanted as
a girl but never got and then she had
you and I knew you'd be the same just as
strange just as abnormal that said
Vernon and petunia somehow believed that
they had been overly kind to Harry
simply by allowing him to live under
their roof despite the terrible way in
which they treated him blinded by their
bitterness towards Harry's unwanted
arrival at number four Private Drive
they seemed to think that they had done
a rather good job at providing for him a
belief we see Albus Dumbledore contest
years later Dumbledore paused and
although his voice remained light and
calm and he gave no obvious sign of
anger Harry felt a kind of chill
emanating from him and noticed that the
dursleys Drew very slightly closer
together you did not do as I asked you
have never treated Harry's a son he has
no nothing but neglect and often cruelty
at your hands the best that can be said
is that he has at least escaped the
appalling damage you have inflicted upon
the unfortunate boy sitting between You
by contrast Dudley and Harry's
relationship with something else
entirely as a child Dudley was simply
the product of being spoiled rotten and
treated like he was better than everyone
around him this resulted in him thinking
he was indeed better than everyone and
this obviously included his cousin Harry
the way he bullied him and talked down
to him was quite obviously a product of
his upbringing fortunately as mentioned
earlier Dudley did seem to redeem
himself somewhat in later years after
Harry saved him from a group of
Dementors and even acknowledged such to
Harry before leaving number four Private
Drive In 1997. I don't think you're a
waste of space if Harry had not seen
Dudley's lips move he might not have
believed it as it was he stared at
Dudley for several seconds before
accepting that it must have been his
cousin who had spoken for one thing that
they had turned red Harry was
embarrassed and astonished himself well
uh thanks Dudley again Dudley appeared
to Grapple with thoughts too unwieldy
for expression before mumbling you saved
my life the dursley's impact on the
Wizarding World although horribly
abusive without the deslies Harry would
not have been kept safe until he came of
age within magical Society it was
through the power of Lily's sacrifice
that one of her surviving blood
relatives petunia was able to carry
through the protective powers that Lily
unknowingly released when she died to
save Harry if Harry had been unable to
call number four privet drive his home
he would have been a lot more vulnerable
to attacks by Voldemort and his Death
Eaters much earlier in his life Harry
may also become a rather different young
man had he not been treated so poorly by
his aunt uncle and cousin while
certainly not the best way to keep voy
humble due to the abuse that Harry
suffered throughout his childhood he
grew up to be an incredibly empathetic
and thoughtful wizard he greatly valued
his friendships and was very grateful
for the kindness he was shown by the
people in his life had he not grown up
bullied and mistreated by the dursley
family the characteristics allowed him
to eventually defeat Voldemort may not
have been the ones that defined him what
happened to the jerseys where are they
now after being ousted from the house
they'd called their home for the better
part of two decades where did they go
what became of Vernon petunia and Dudley
presumably after piling into their
family car the dursleys went in search
of a new safer and more secure location
and as mentioned they were even offered
assistance from the Order of the Phoenix
to go into hiding from Voldemort and his
army of Death Eaters but where exactly
they went is still somewhat of an
unknown whether they attempted to find
someplace safe on their own or accepted
the help of the order also remains a
mystery three however it's been
suggested that after the fall of
Voldemort the doses were eventually
escorted back to their home in little
whinging presumably by the order making
it likely that in the end they did
accept help from that lot as Vernon was
known to call them from there many
believe that Vernon and petunia then
continued to reside at number four
perfect drive for the rest of their
lives although I'm not entirely sure I
believe this to be true I've mentioned
in the past that I actually think that
after all the chaos of The Wizarding war
and complete lack of normalcy they may
not have been able to Simply return to
number four privet drive and resume
their regular lives as before not to
mention that Vernon would have been with
grunnings for nearly 30 years at this
point putting him in a rather good
position for retirement so I personally
think this would have been an excellent
opportunity for Vernon and petunia to
start a new Dudley likely could have
gone off to college at this point and
Harry was no longer their responsibility
so it's entirely possible that they
decided to retired to say a tropical
climate of sorts perhaps a beachfront
property on Majorca here Vernon and
petunia could have made a comfortable
and ordinary life for themselves sipping
drinks on the beach and congratulating
themselves on a job well done at raising
their son and living completely
unremarkable lives sadly I don't think
Vernon and petunia would have made any
efforts to stay in touch with their
nephew Vernon was obviously quite open
about his dislike for Harry or the boy
as he preferred to call him whereas
petunia who seemed to secretly Harbor
some sentimentality and perhaps even
love towards Harry was altogether too
stubborn and proud of a person who ever
tried to reconcile as a result I think
the dursleys former estrangement with
the Potters probably transferred onto
Harry his future wife Jenny and their
three children James Albus and Lily on
the other hand after the second
Wizarding war ended it's been suggested
that Harry and Dudley went on to have a
relationship of sorts although rather
formal and little bit strained the
interactions between the two at the very
least existed or JK Rowling has revealed
that she always thought that Harry and
Dudley did in fact have a relationship
with one another exchanging holiday
cards and getting their two families
together on occasion Harry and Dudley
would still see each other enough to be
on Christmas card terms but they would
visit more out of a sense of Duty and
sit in silence so that their children
could see their cousins with this
information we can also gather that
Dudley eventually got married and had a
family of his own raising two Michael
children with his wife
so it would appear as though Dudley
continued to become a better man than he
was as a child revealing that he was not
as pig-headed as his father very little
is known as to whether the dursleys are
still alive however there are some
Revelations on this topic within the
cursed child I'm certainly not
suggesting that this is Canon but I do
think it's worth mentioning in the play
Harry tells his son about his baby
blanket and in doing so reveals that his
Aunt Petunia has died something that
Dudley shared with him when returning
the blanket to Harry which he found
among his mum's things while cleaning
out her possessions this is the last
thing I had for my mum the only thing I
was given to the Des is wrapped in it I
thought it had gone forever and then
when your great Aunt Petunia died hidden
amongst her possession surprisingly
Dudley found this and he kindly sent it
on to me and ever since then well any
time I've wanted luck I found it and
just tried to hold it and with that
we've come to the end of another video
what did you think what did I miss
please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel who
should I cover the history of next also
be sure to check out the content on
Spotify as well as extra content on my
second Channel Harry Potter Theory extra
until next time remember I don't think
you're a waste of space
foreign